[Musica]
da circa due anni
per andare al lavoro impiego poco tempo
il tragitto sicuramente più corto ma
anche la scelta dei vestiti è molto più
semplice una maglietta o una felpa a
seconda del freddo reatino e pantaloni
rigorosamente lunghi
una volta salita macchina arrivo a lago
di ripasottile che la mattina dorme con
la sua copertina di nebbia e l'edificio
grande delle idrovore che va da
guardiano
poco più avanti
arrivo al mio giardino
a rompere il silenzio ci sono otto gatti
affamati che mi aspettano facciamo
colazione insieme e il sole quando la
mattina molto presto incomincia a salire
e la luce filtra tra le particelle
sospese
è un mondo incantato
ganino però i colori da te ne diventano
sempre più vivi hilbert e poi il giallo
il rosso e infine colori molto più copy
seguendo la tavolozza delle stagioni in
piena fioritura quello che faccio in
genere
dedicarmi
all'inizio alla raccolta
quindi vado dove coltivo i fiori eletti
e raccolgo i fiori
in questo modo
questo
momento è molto delicato per una farmer
come me perché ci permette di notare da
più vicino i fiori le necessità delle
piante e
se ci sono ad esempio delle invasioni di
insetti non previste o delle malattie
quindi una volta raccolti fiori li
colleziono in the vasi che poi porto
dentro la mia stalla che è un
laboratorio di floral designer quindi mi
dedico alla creazione di bouquet
o allestimenti presenti ci sono
tantissime varie attività ma come ci
sono del resto anche in campo quando
finisco la raccolta dei fiori
incominciamo a fare i lavori quelli un
po più duri che mi garantiscono
purtroppo un'abbronzatura sempre con la
manica stampata e
incomincio a togliere erbacce mettere in
sicurezza le piante insomma ci sono
tantissime attività che vanno però dalla
progettazione del giardino quindi porre
un seme o un bulbo un tubero e poi il
trapianto quindi durante la mia attività
durante l'anno seguo da vicino ogni
passo che mi porta poi a fa vedere
fiorito il mio giardino
vi starete chiedendo
immagino che cosa faccio io una flowers
farm di flower pharma nel mondo ne
esistono davvero tante e in realtà
l'etichetta anglosassone l'abbiamo anche
recepita qui in italia per indicare
delle aziende agricole che si dedicano
alla coltivazione di fiori in modo
stagionale quindi non c'è una forzatura
dei fiori e in pieno campo senza
l'utilizzo di pesticidi e seguendo un
approccio quindi organico c'è una
motivazione un po triste da una parte ma
anche molto felice e
vorrei
girare un attimino la medaglia e
mostrarlo invece quello che c'è nel
resto del mondo e quello che è il
settore della floricoltura
sapete ad esempio dove avete comprato i
fiori che avete regalato una persona che
amate
oppure quelli che utilizzate per dire
arrivederci a una persona cara o quelli
che vi hanno portato all'altare o dal
vostro compagno i fiori fanno parte
della nostra quotidianità perché
bellezza allo stato puro ma nessuna si
pone la domanda da dove vengono quei
fiori oltre il negozio chi è li produce
beh se ad esempio poniamo il caso di
trovarci a febbraio quando a san
valentino in genere si regalano le rose
chi ha un giardino saprà che le rose in
quel periodo non esistono non esistono
perché è troppo freddo bisogna aspettare
maggio le temperature quando si alzano
sicuramente aiutano il fiora sbocciare
alcune volte anche ripetutamente ma non
non di certo qui in italia succede
questo a febbraio e quindi siccome le
stagioni sono invertite a sud
dell'equatore
è proprio il momento ottimale per
coltivare questi fiori
e al sud dell'equatore ci sono interi
continenti nazioni insomma dove i
produttori si sono spostati per
dedicarsi alla industrializzazione del
fiore quindi ci sono delle grandissime
serve piene di fiori
solitamente monocoltura quindi si
specializzano e li coltivano sfruttando
persone e purtroppo anche
elementi che danneggiano gravemente
l'ambiente e la salute
uno di questi ad esempio può essere
diritti che qui in italia e in europa
non si può più utilizzare ma lì non è
normato e quindi
le flowers pharma in questo senso
cercano di risolvere un problema molto
grande e
proponendo una soluzione
locale stagionale appunto come vede
raccontavo e questo ha delle dei
riscontri positivi
sotto vari punti di vista ad esempio
sapreste riconoscere
questo fiore
oppure
questo che allo stesso
sono tali
o anche
questo più piccolino che in genere nei
campi promo soliti vedere nelle tonalità
dell'azzurro
le frogger farm sono un posto
meraviglioso dove si coltivano fiori di
ogni tipo di ogni varietà questo tipo di
fiore è molto delicato e
se fosse coltivato al sud dell'equatore
purtroppo dovrebbe viaggiare in degli
aerei ibernato arrivare in olanda
dall'olanda poi forza arrivare nelle
grandi città e dulcis in fondo al
negozio e a voi è un
tempo molto lungo il fiore ha una durata
brevissima rispetto all'apertura o alla
frutta deperisce e per questo le fra per
far
sono quella quel posto magico dove
potete trovare meraviglie del genere che
possono essere utilizzate per voi o o
perché volete
nella mia flowers pharma ad esempio
quest'anno ho coltivato più di 300
varietà di fiori diversi e la cosa molto
buona e che tornano a fiorire i
fiordalisi e specie che in realtà sono
estinte
almeno a livello spontaneo perché non
utilizzo per suicide non utilizzo nulla
di tutto ciò e lo faccio con immenso
amore tutti i giorni da due anni a
questa parte
fino a due anni fa la mia attività era
sicuramente diversa sono un ingegnere e
ho sempre cercato la mia strada non
sapendo di preciso quale fosse almeno da
bambina sognavo di diventare una cuoca
poi un astronauta e così via poi a un
certo punto mi sono ritrovato a
scegliere la carriera da ingegnere l'ho
portata a termine
e proprio quando effettivamente
avevo il modo di fare insomma di dare un
giusto valore anche a tutto il tempo che
aveva impiegato negli studi e
nella mia quotidianità mi sono tirata
indietro la cosa bella che ancora non
avevo capito cosa sarei andata a fare
poi guardando un pochino su internet ho
scoperto questo bellissimo mondo delle
prove per far me ha detto wow i fiori
forse potrebbero essere quell elemento
che mi permette di essere creativa di
esprimermi
in tutti i sensi perché un fiore ha
colore profumo ha delle forme quelli che
coltiviamo nelle prove per far ma non
sono sempre così dritti come uno si
aspetterebbe perché il clima influisce
su tutto anche sulla forma e tutto
questo mi è attualmente dal 26 us mato
che ho deciso di abbandonare sì la mia
carriera ma di intraprendere una strada
che non conoscevo non ho mai avuto il
pollice verde ho sempre fatto morire
qualsiasi tipo di pianta e è assurdo che
oggi ho un giardino pieno di fiori e
una delle prove per parma che mi ha
aperto gli occhi su questo mondo
florette dove ha seguito anche un corso
perché è veramente difficile coltivare
fiori e se non si studia è più una
passione
poi sicuramente l'esperienza insegna
un'esperienza che
durante l'anno bisogna
aspettare se si sbaglia
l'anno prossimo forse si risolverà il
problema forse no forse il fiore non è
adatto a questo luogo insomma ci sono
tantissimi aspetti e
la mia strada si può dire che
stata segnata sicuramente e dalla
presenza dei miei nonni che si sono
sempre dedicati alla natura
la mia nonna e
che tuttora come metro di misura
utilizza l'orto o le galline per dire se
sta bene quindi se va nell'orto fa
benissimo altrimenti insomma forse
qualche problemino c'è però 94 anni è
comprensibile anche mio padre appena può
sul trattore e e io forse sono sempre
rimasto un po in bilico non sapevo cosa
fare e
siccome ero portata dal desiderio di
riavvicinarmi alla natura ho compiuto un
passo enorme perché comunque ci vuole
coraggio per abbandonare determinate
certezze incamminarsi su una strada dove
non assolutamente non conoscevo nulla e
nonostante tutto oggi sono qui a
parlarvi di questo sperando che anche
voi un giorno se scegliate dei fiori
sicuramente locali ponendo un attimino
l'attenzione su tutto il processo su
tutto quello che c'è dietro perché non
c'è bisogno di mangiare qualcosina per
rendersi conto che si può fare di meglio
e si aiutano anche tantissime realtà
sofferenti per determinate situazioni e
anche la terra e
vorrei concludere con una frase di
bruciato che è una giardiniera inglese
che in un posto dove il primo
praticamente per i giardinieri è
perfetto ha studiato affinché riuscisse
a costruire un giardino roccioso quindi
con delle piante che non richiedono
grandi risorse idriche e lo ha fatto
perché ogni pianta secondo questa
giardiniera deve essere coltivata nello
spazio che le appartiene quindi non deve
essere forzato
e come io alla fine sono diventata una
pianta che è ritornata a casa
praticamente
questa veramente molto vicino a me e
così in modo spontaneo senza
[Musica]
sentirmi fuori luogo ma parte integrante
dell'ambiente che sto costruendo auguro
anche a voi di essere piante forti che
affondino le radici in un terreno ricco
perché un terreno ricco fa la differenza
assolutamente su ogni tipo di
coltivazione e di mostrare al mondo la
vostra bellezza come fanno i fiori per
me spero che i fiori
siano veramente qualcosa che nutre la
vostra anima e che voi lo siate per il
mondo grazie
[Musica]